think of your favorite deity male/female
or giant crocodile it doesn't really
matter now it's likely that their day t
has a specific field or domain
associated of them for example the god
of the sky the goddess of wisdom or
perhaps a deity associated to something
as abstract as time it's then very easy
to identify these deities because of
what they're associated with and these
associations commonly branch out to
other things a god or goddess associated
of numerous ideas is not uncommon but
with Hermes we have a jack-of-all-trades
and a God of many titles the messenger
the trickster and the conductor of souls
are just a few the sheer number of
things that homies is considered to be
the patron of is just one of the many
reasons that he is perhaps the most
unique date in the Greek pantheon we
mentioned a few of his largest roles
being the messenger of the gods and the
conductor of souls in the afterlife but
Hermes was also considered the god of
trade merchants wealth in commerce as
well as language crossroads sports
athletes boundaries borders thieves
graves and heraldry and yet somehow was
still not finished because he was also
the patron of shepherds the protector of
travelers and the divine trickster so I
think it's fair to say the ancient
Greeks couldn't exactly avoid the
worship of Hermes the earliest
depictions of Hermes can be traced all
the way back to the Mycenaeans who
referred to him as Omega which isn't too
different to how the Greeks pronounced
his name today with the H almost been
silent or sounded more like air who we
call Hermes the Greeks cool Hermes the
exact origins of the name homies aren't
exactly to Claire but quite a few
scholars believed it to have originated
from the word homer which referred to a
heap of stones that marked a boundary
from this then derived the word homie or
Hawaii which were a set of boundary
markers used by travelers dedicated to
Hermes and thus we can explain his
association with travelers boundaries
and borders just like the vast majority
of Olympians it should come as no
surprise to anyone that Hermes was a
child of Zeus his mother on the other
hand was a nymph named Maya the eldest
of the Pleiades the seven daughters of
Atlas according to popular legend Zeus
visited Mount Cellini the home of
alice's daughters it was here during the
dead of night that he would impregnate
Maya and somehow by the crack of dawn
Hermes would be born the idea of a child
being conceived and born within
des would certainly seem more than
strange but when we consider the fact
that the homies possessed unmeasurable
speed a birth that took mere hours
certainly isn't the weirdest thing we've
seen thus far the first thing Maya did
was wrap her newborn son in swaddling
bands to keep him safe ah she herself
rested but even as a newborn baby we
start to see the trickster side of
Hermes he managed to eventually squirm
free of the swaddling bands and the
first thing he did was run all the way
from Arcadia to Thessaly where his
brother Apollo graced his prized cattle
Hermes then stole several of the herd
and took them back home where he hid
them in a small grotto near the city of
pilots but that wasn't enough adventure
for the newborn Hermes on his way back
to his cave he caught and killed an
enormous tortoise using its entrails to
create the first liar
Apollo believed in at his cattle had in
fact been stolen then traveled to mount
Cellini informing Maya that he believed
homeys was responsible Maya tonin see
her son still wrapped where she left him
claimed that Apollo's accusations could
physically not be possible however Zeus
had been watching his newborn son quite
closely and though he was amused by his
antics he demanded that he returned the
cattle Hermes then proceeded to take out
the lyre that he previously made and
began to play the music was so
enchanting that Apollo just had to have
this instrument and so he made Hermes an
offer he could keep the cattle that he
had previously stolen but in exchange he
would have to give Apollo this new
instrument Hermes of course
orchestrating this entire situation did
not hesitate to accept the offer the
lyre would go on to become one of
Apollo's many symbols and he would
eventually become a grand master of the
instrument all thanks to his cunning
baby brother Hermes the story not only
explains Hermes association with thieves
cattle and shepherds but we also get a
brief insight into his interest and
talent when it came to music not to
mention how cunning homeys was being
able to tricking out with his brother
despite being born in that very same day
for those of you wondering about the
Roman or the Etruscan counterpart to
Hermes he went by the name of mercury
and to be honest they were quite similar
the Romans however did manage to narrow
down Mercury's patronage to mostly just
Commerce and travel so with Hermes now
all no longer been a baby we can take a
look at his numerous lovers children and
I guess overall
and being the son of Zeus homies had
countless siblings a list that is far
too long for me to go over in just one
video but we can use the rule that if it
came from Zeus than it was most likely
related to Hermes similar to his father
Hermes had many nymph and human lovers
with the most famous of these being dry
Oh pay and Merapi along with these nooks
in humans Hermes also had numerous
romantic relations and affairs with
other goddesses including fato the
goddess of persuasion and seduction
Aphrodite the goddess of love and her
karta the goddess of magic like many of
the other Greek gods Hermes had numerous
children but these children never really
reached the heights of fame and
notoriety of the other Greek gods
offspring the child that I'm sure many
of you have heard of is the god of the
wild pan who does have many different
fathers but there are stories that claim
his parents were in fact Hermes in dry
obey I'm not entirely sure who I'd
consider pans father but Hermes and
Pandu certainly share some
characteristics such as they're fun
laid-back and trickster like nature when
you couple this with his impressive
strength and speed Hermes being his
father is definitely a distinct
possibility his other children of note
included Taiki the goddess of fortune
and prosperity whom was mothered by
Aphrodite together Aphrodite Hermes had
another child by the name of
hermaphrodite as' an extremely handsome
young boy who fell in love with a nymph
named Sal MacOS Sal Mac has prayed for
the two to be united forever and
eventually her prayers would be answered
but perhaps not in the way that the two
wished as they will merge together
creating one androgynous form both man
and woman hence their name been a
compound of homeys and Aphrodite and
later been the origins for the word
hermaphrodite the rest of homies his
children are either beautiful maidens or
minor heroes
these included marital asada was an
Amazon uterus who was one of the kilise
five commanders in the Trojan War and
lastly Angelia who followed in her
father's footsteps becoming a spirit of
messages tidings and proclamation with
Hermes being born on Mount Cellini in
Arcadia it's no real surprise that that
is the oldest known location of his
worship some believe that the first
temple dedicated to Hermes was
constructed by king like Cohen the king
of Arcadia who was turned into a wolf by
Zeus because of the sheer amount of
things that fell under the patronage of
Hermes naturally his worship would
spread across the entire country
with a rather large count located in
Athens which then radiated through the
whole land of temples and statutes been
seen everywhere
the statues of Hermes commonly depicted
him as a young teen and that's because
many saw his role as helping or guiding
the young into adulthood this was most
common among hunters and soldiers as
they would often have some kind of
ceremony that signified their transition
from childhood into adulthood these
often took the form of a specific hunt
or battle regardless of which these were
extremely stressful times for what we
were considered today to be just
children the image of homies at a
similar age to these children we can
assume bought them a certain degree of
comfort and provided them with the
confidence they needed to face their
coming trials and tribulations during
these festivals honoring Hermes it was
commonplace to see animals such as goats
lambs and pigs along with the customary
cakes and honey however some of these
festivals involved more than just a
simple sacrifice in the name of Hermes
the hemay were series of festivals that
celebrated athletics and gymnastics and
it was fairly commonplace for adults to
be excluded from these festivals because
they were seen as the initiation for a
young boy to become a man a large
portion of Hermes followers were also
made up of farmers and shepherds because
of his association with nature and
cattle they would look to Hermes to keep
their cattle healthy as well as safe and
out of the way of Thieves
which is quite ironic when you think
about it because thieves in need of
guidance would often turn to Hermes so
who exactly Hermes would help in this
situation
I don't really know maybe he flipped a
coin or maybe he just ignored them all
there are also those that believe Hermes
was capable of travelling through
different planes of existence driftin in
between whenever he was needed and that
is how he could so easily travel between
our land and the land of the dead being
able to see worlds that were invisible
to mortals as well as other deities when
we see statues of homies he usually
appears as a fairly young man were in a
wind cap and winged sandals hold in the
caduceus his wings staff entwined of two
serpents which also served as his
primary symbol his other many symbols
included the rooster the RAM the hawk
the tortoise the lyre and the strawberry
tree the trait however that most people
recognize Hermes form is of course his
remarkable speed now for those of you
wondering how fast Hermes was I can't
really give you a number in terms of
miles per hour but my extremely super
professional guests would be really
really fast
hermès was also an extremely intelligent
individual and there were times he may
appear as a bit of a trickster by no
means does that mean he was evil or
cruel he appeared to have quite a strong
connection to humankind when he wasn't
tricking the other gods for his own
amusement it would be to help humanity
in some stories homies were sent by Zeus
to share his knowledge of humanity and
teach them the value of justice to help
form a relationship between mortal and
God and this arguably could be why
homies show so much favor to humanity
over time the image of Hermes began to
change
similar telev Dionysus he appeared as a
mature bearded man dressed as a traveler
and this highlighted the more
intelligent friend and teacher to
humanity which definitely paints a nice
contrast between the young scantily
clothed athletic depictions of Hermes
there isn't much said about his time in
the underworld but we know he was a
conductor of souls helping furry the
dead to Hades he would take his golden
staff and send the dead into a deep
slumber and whilst in his trance Hermes
would guide them through the dark and
treacherous paths before them the next
time they woke they would be in Hades
and this process also led many to
believe that Hermes was a God of sleep
and the dreams of omen which were
messages sent by the dead it's believed
that after the adoption of Persephone
when Hermes was sent to bring her back
he was soon after appointed the guide of
dead souls
apart from Hades Persephone and her
karta Hermes was the only other day T
ever really allowed to leave the
underworld without any repercussions or
consequence if we take a look at the
love story of Orpheus and Eurydice when
she's granted one day on earth to see
her husband it is Hermes who escorts her
to Orpheus and then back to Hades so now
we finally move on to the stories of
Hermes appeared in the story of homies
stealing Apollo's cat was a child is
definitely one of his most well known
stories but perhaps the most celebrated
was his Battle of August Penna pitous
the giant with one hundred eyes the
story begins with Hera well-being Hera
by transforming a woman named IO into a
cow because she was jealous that Zeus
loved her she then placed the giant
Penna pitous the war scene to guard the
cow in some stories it was actually Zeus
who transformed IO into a cow and
attempt to hide her from Hera but she
demanded the cow from Zeus and once
again assigned the giant to guard her
Hermes was then instructed by Zeus to
steal the cow but the giant was warned
of his arrival and so he was unable to
sneak past the giant force and said to
slay him in battle
Hermes then used his staff to close all
100 of the Giants eyes sending him into
a deep slumber he then cut off the
drunks head of his golden swords and
threw it off a cliff onto the rocks
below when the Giants then marched in
Olympus Hermes killed the giant he
polito's with his gold sword when quite
often Hermes can be seen would in this
cold sword in battle Hermes also played
a part in defeating the biggest giant of
all - when Zeus faced - alone for the
very first time he actually lost and
after this encounter - cut out Zeus his
tendons leaving him powerless and
defeated Hermes however was not amongst
the gods who had transformed themselves
into animals and fled to Egypt he
instead came to aid his father stealing
back the tendons and restoring the power
that - had stolen from Zeus Hermes also
appears in some stories that we can
consider a bit more mainstream help in
Perseus to feed Medusa and convincing
Calypso to free Odysseus and his men he
also regularly appears in Aesop's fables
one of my favorite stories is the reason
why Aesop believes that all craftsmen
are liars and why cobblers were the
worst of them Zeus ordered homeys to
instill a dose of deceit in every
craftsman and so Hermes took a pestle
and mortar and began to grind the drug
of deceitfulness into a fine powder he
then applied it equally to all craftsmen
except for one
the last Crossman was the cobbler and
there was a large amount of powder left
and so homies took the remaining content
of the mortar and poured it onto the
cobbler making him the most dishonest
craftsman and there are so many stories
that feature Hermes that just like he's
many children and lovers if I sat here
trying to explain them all to you I'd be
here all day however in terms of his
fellow Olympians he would often
challenge them to the Greek games as
well as regularly playing tricks on them
stealing artemis Aceros Aphrodite's
girdle an on occasion even taking the
Trident of Poseidon and there aren't too
many deities brave enough to risk
angering Poseidon but Hermes was clearly
one of them
personally I really like Hermes and not
just because he's basically the God of
everything but because the tricksters
naca type you don't really see much in
Greek myth and Hermes is definitely not
your ordinary trickster despite all of
his responsibilities he still somehow
finds time to show his more fun sight
playing tricks on the gods while never
neglect in his own duties helping
countless others and fighting numerous
battles I do also find it extremely
funny that he was conceived and born
within a day and the first thing he did
as a newborn baby was steal his brothers
cattle Hermes very clearly cares about
his fellow gods and he's firmly helping
them out whenever he can but he also
never really backs down when it comes to
helping humanity regardless of the
consequence from his fellow gods or
goddesses I guess what makes hermie such
a likeable respected figure was the fact
that he just does everything and
whatever he chooses to do he happens to
be extremely good at he has all of the
positive aspects and likeable
characteristics you'd want to expect
from a God without much of the negative
the phrase jack of all trades and master
of none comes to mind but Hermes is
literally a jack of all trades and a
master of all so let me know what you
think about homies in the comments below
did you know the sheer amount of things
at the helmet as a patron of are there
any stories involving homies that you
particularly enjoy and are there any
aspects of homies that you would
consider negative let me know in the
comments below as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained
[Music]